i'm not going to lie i like to play a
good eroge you know
yeah we all know this man lived off when
he was 13.
just played a little euphoria and little
just playing okay
because like i i mean to arrogance but i
never had the balls to try before okay
okay it was so good i was like oh
euphoria can i kind of
can i tell the story i catch you
actually yeah let's put let's put them
like in your face
how did you first find out about
euphoria um
i heard somebody talk about it but i
didn't really like they didn't say
anything bad about it they just said oh
it's like kind of like a death game and
i
you know i really like horror i like
death games i have no idea what this is
by the way i'm sure there's a lot of
poop
oh okay okay we'll we'll get we'll get
into that oh yeah i mean you're not
wrong yeah
absolutely so what one day sydney's just
like messing about on her computer and
she just casually asked me
hey god have you heard of this uh anime
hentai called euphoria
i'm like yeah why she's like i'm
i'm i'm thinking about playing it i'm
like oh
okay um that's a pretty infamous game
and she
she kept she keeps asking me why why is
infamous what's this
what's so infamous about this game it's
like the same energy as your mum coming
like what is bang bros
why do i have a subscription to pornhub
on in my mail
right here what is x hamster on yeah
and so i just go you know what sydney
why not just download it and play it
and why would you say that and see what
happens because already
you love this woman no it's resulted in
probably one of my favorite twitter
threads online because i told her to
document her experience
with it and so she has this twitter
thread of like
of her like fresh experience with
euphoria which we can probably pull out
because i
was so certain that you were
overreacting if i'm honest i was so
certain like i've seen my fair share of
a rogue
i know i've played black or bible black
okay
like i'm like oh is somebody just gonna
like accidentally puke or something and
everyone's just like this is
disgusting oh the moment i saw that
twitter thread being started i was like
oh was one of the few twitter threads
where you can literally grab the popcorn
and just scroll down because there has
never been a more well-documented
like journey of someone losing their
mind
because i think it was it was never the
same after you played euphoria and you
released that euphoria video i think
that was like your
your first really dive into full
degeneracy i
of course i played like a rogue like
sometimes like someone you want to
explain what euphoria is to someone like
connor
and people who don't have no idea what
euphoria is i just know there's poop and
eating it
oh i wish it was just yeah i wish i wish
we could say that's the word can we do a
youtube friendly version so we don't get
completely
i think essentially everything grows
that you can even think of on the top of
your head in the next three seconds
it's in euphoria so euphoria is the kind
of game where
sorry so euphoria is a game where
this one guy who suddenly starts to
realize he's a sadistic [ __ ] who
enjoys like
girls pains is stuck in a room with um
like
seven other girls and um they give him
acts that he has to do otherwise they
somebody dies and gets
like gets killed basically like soul
yeah essentially but like
eating [ __ ] and so like they have
essentially every weird tank
they have like diaper wearing and
[ __ ] and you have to eat the [ __ ]
out of the diaper
they have like there's a furry
convention
oh god taking your thing to another one
oh my god dude this sounds too much for
youtube but i think i get a picture of
how disgusting it is a lot here
and so that defines your youtube career
unfortunately
so you may you read you watch that or
you experience it you're like
this is it this is my magnum this is my
peak this is what we're going to follow
to be fair like i made a video because
i'm like i thought nobody else knew that
euphoria was this bad i thought they
thought that what i did i thought
everybody else thought it was like a
death game and i'm like
i'm warning you guys and too little did
i know i'm the [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] over
here
so well i mean someone had to experience
it
yeah yeah i've just taken the l for
everybody
one thing i'm sure a lot of people have
been curious about is obviously like
you're a female who's like very into
hentai but like
how did you get into hentai originally
like what opens the gate for you
and what like what what made what made
it appealing to you
to like because the general consensus is
females don't read hentai yeah exactly
right
it's just more of like in case you guys
didn't know i grew up
or i was born and raised in a small
village in wisconsin near milwaukee
and wouldn't you think it they're pretty
conservative
so i didn't have a sex education and i
got all of my sex education from
actually from yeah hentai
this is going like the good christian
girl room
like i had no idea that like jizz was
like
looked like anything like i didn't know
like stuff came out
i was 17 when i learned that jizz
existed oh my god oh my
god i didn't even know
our sex education was more of like stay
abstinent
don't do it yeah i've seen a bunch of
those right it's like you can either
teach sex education or tell them to not
just not [ __ ] not do any of yeah
we had a sex ed but it wasn't sex ed
it's more of like
but um so i actually learned i didn't
know that
hentai really existed until i um it was
actually very similar to garn story
where i
like found a random link to bible black
and i downloaded it and then i saw just
like a girl like growing a dick and i'm
like can girls do that
you wouldn't know you weren't sure
how do i grab penis like guys can jizz
can girls grow
dicks is that just the thing that my
parents have just not taught me
essentially but um so i think from there
just my interest grew because i was just
like
well this is the only segment yeah
so then i just kind of dived in and
actually some of it had good stories and
it wasn't just
[ __ ] and then just life changed from
there
so what else like some early hentai that
you actually like properly enjoyed
because because as a as like a teenager
i'm sure most guys
we had one purpose of why we like got
into hentai we didn't really care about
the plot that much
i still don't care about the plot yeah
he still doesn't but
someone from your perspective i feel
would you know have have something
different uh
well definitely when i first started
like watching hentai in a rogue you know
was just to get like
you know just kind of like the what is
this warm feeling in my pants
but then but then i started like my
first real aerogate that i liked
was you made me do
and um it was just like about depression
and just like and this guy's just having
sex with these depressed girls and i'm
like oh my god
i'm having feels well my my pants are
warm
oh my god
there's like a million other ways you
could have phrased it
you didn't have to say warm feeling in
my pants it's like
it's like the worst way you could afford
it oh my god
so yeah essentially you made a was the
first one and then obviously
uh you know i was like once with good
stories
stories and then i kind of started going
for like the generally like
hey this isn't just sex this is a good
plot you know kind of like one of those
porns like you see
and it's like somehow one of those lines
just sticks with you yeah yeah
i've never seen a an actual porno i'm
like damn this story's good
i mean the only like quotable porn like
horrible ones yeah yeah yeah you didn't
get my cereal yeah
i think she wants me to suck my mic
wait i gotta i gotta ask conor have you
ever watched like a hentai
and just watched the entire run time no
skipping no no
no skipping just watch an entire episode
without without skipping i'm hitting
that button
i'll look at the i'll look at the watch
i'm like i've got 10 minutes i can watch
the intro
i got time i can watch the intro and
then i'm normally just disappointed and
like i wish i just didn't know your
personality
i'm like the characters normally i like
regret that i learned that just means
you haven't seen the good ones yet yeah
well i think i've seen some good ones
like i
i mean i don't know what else myself
so i'm gonna save it uh you know gotta
keep some aces in there well then while
sydney's here then what is yours like
what would you say is like the absolute
peak of like yes this is the best one
i've seen yeah
to be fair i don't re or uh i don't
watch a lot of like animated hentai
because you know once you've seen one
honestly you kind of seen them all like
it all looks the same
they're all based off the dojins though
yeah
well a lot of them are based on
variegate yeah yeah yeah and like even
if they were based off the dojins it was
like or
like hentai manga it was just like kind
of like it doesn't keep the good [ __ ]
you know it's not as beautiful it
doesn't keep the plots
it doesn't create the plot and even the
sex scenes that they copy that are like
hot in the
dojins aren't hot in anime yeah i don't
know like
especially some dojians especially if
they're animated by queen bee
oh my god i do not talk about queen i
don't know how queen bee can take some
of the like
best dogens like s here joe dojins and
make it seem like
worsely animated than the [ __ ] manga
itself there have been so many
where like i'm into the idea of the
story i'm watching the cut scenes and
then i forget i'm still watching queen
bee
and then and then this the two pngs
start rubbing against each other and i'm
like oh
some queen bee stuff i've seen is like
they they must have animated this on
like powerpoint
yeah there's no animation because the
the the worst thing about queen bee
is that they're like the posters
yeah queen bee is a hentai studio quite
infamous if you watch enough hentai for
just
having the worst animation you can
imagine foreign
i think queen bee was one of the first
studios that forced me to like research
hentai studios right because normally
like hentai hentai
animation isn't the same animation isn't
the greatest
but it's like it's it's possible but
queen bee was so bad that it forced me
to have to google search why does these
certain hentais look this bad
oh okay it's because the same it's
because the same studios are animating
it